I always say in videos that I know are going
to get people responding to things I did not
say. Watch the video first and then comment.
Watch the video first and then comment. And
unfortunately someone showed up on our subreddit
and posted about my recent Iran, Trump, Venezuela,
Russia, Putin video. Has pacman completely
lost it. Trump has to attack Iran to proof
he is not putting Russia's interest before
Americas. And of course I didn't say any of
that.
And this is clearly someone who either didn't
watch the video or didn't understand it or
understood it and is pretending not to have
understood it. I am not saying there is any
kind of conspiracy between Donald Trump and
Putin personally for Trump to take foreign
policy actions that Putin has dictated to
them. It a zoomed out view of in the end Trump
is deferring or ending up with the foreign
policy decisions that protect Russia's interests
or would be the decisions Putin would prefer.
That is as far as I went, it was a correlation
discussion, not a causation discussion. Please
watch the videos before responding. That should
just be a rule. A also on the David Pakman
show, sub reddit. Yes. Somebody found uh,
images and video of when I produced a basketball
skills video. I was not the instructor. You
will be glad to know, but I did play the um,
a defender and sometimes often fence player
to help the instructor.
This is when I produced videos for expert
village and he how I was like 22 years old
and if you want to see something really funny,
you can find this on our sub reddit. You can
also find it easily. If you follow me on Instagram
at David Dot. Pacman, it is me holding a basketball,
helping out in the production of these basketball
basics videos and it is pretty funny. And
listen at 22. That was, it was good money
for producing those instructional videos.
I'm glad that I did it. Uh, check those out
and thanks to everybody who has been screenshotting
the funniest moments from the videos. Really
appreciate waking up every day and seeing
that on the sub reddit. Join the discussion@davidpakman.com
slash r e. D. D. I. T.